richard first of all we're super excited
to have you join the champions chess or
what's your expectations to now play uh
online rapid tour
[Music]
yeah good question i don't have a
two high hopes to
to do really really well but on the
other hand you know okay it's not not
much different from
from on the board chess so yeah i will
just try to you know um play my best
chess and see what happens what should
we expect from you in in this format
online rapid how good are you uh i i
don't think i'm i'm too good yeah
but uh yeah i mean i think certainly i'm
worse than on the board and i'm not that
great on the board either
i tried to
play
the best movie in the position you know
according to
my ability whether it's tactical or
positional but uh yeah somehow uh
my views tend to differ from uh the
other players but
to me to me it looks you know i'm just
trying to play the best move i don't
have a specific style so would you say
like you're aggressive or you know you
take a lot of risks yeah i would say i
used to be more aggressive so i don't
know where i'm now but i i can see that
with the age you know comes with them so
knowing my limits maybe yeah
or at least pretending that i know my
limits
how about weaknesses then
knowing my limits
is it the same yeah probably i don't
know yeah i tend
you know i tend to sometimes
try to play things to save i think or at
least you know
what
painful experiences taught me that
sometimes you need to play it safe
you